you ready are these I'll ever be
it will kill
the Zulu equa all right that's cool
was introduced by the famous Zulu King
Shaka he reigned over the Zulu Empire's
expansion through southern Africa from
1816 to 1828. a celebrated warrior in
his own right Shaka developed a number
of military improvements for the Zulu
including the mandatory adoption of the
aqua replacing long light throwing
Spears the equal was shorter and
featured a blade at least 10 inches long
the spear wasn't thrown rather it was
thrust into the enemy and would be
carried along with a cowhide Shield
it was a fearsome weapon utilized
against British colonialists trying to
expand their African colonies the Zulu
equal was also wielded by Zulu warriors
in the classic film Zulu
the equal was of African weapon used by
the Zulu warriors
though it's a short spear it also acted
like a sword because of its design to
see how sharp your blades are I will
take your weapon and try to cut through
the slab of meat while you're up first
you ready yes sir I'm ready
okay
well Lyle your handle over here allows
me to grip and give it more weight at
the tip so when acting like a sword you
can really feel the power when you're
dropping down and as you can see it cut
cleanly through the meat over also your
weapon a little cut good job thank you
Matt you're up next you ready let's do
it seeing last blade cut like it did I'm
going ah crap I'm so nervous right now
okay Matt
a very light weapon like this if held
like a slashing sword could be an issue
when you have a rounded handle makes it
kind of hard to index but the important
thing is it will cut good job thank you
this is a kill test the equa was so
deadly because up close you could use it
in different ways and maneuver the blade
to see how much lethal damage your
weapon can do I will deliver 4 killing
blows on this ballistic study while
you're up first you ready yes sir I'm
ready
oh
well I'll your weapon here feels good in
the hand definitely it's easy to
maneuver the blade in different ways
it's so sharp that it lacerated and
disemboweled the gut right here it cut
through all the way into the sternum
right there lacerating and then right
into the heart your weapon sir will kill
thank you all right Matt you're next you
ready let's do it
foreign
T your leather wrapping on the handle
here made it very comfortable your Edge
over here is very sharp it lacerated
deep into the guts it went all the way
into the ribs the thrust deep into the
abdomen overall sir your weapon will
kill thank you all right next stop is a
strength test Dave so gentlemen what
we're going to do to test the strength
is we're going to tap the tip of your
blade into these blocks of wood and then
pry them to the side if your blades are
tempered properly it should hold up
beautifully and just pry a piece of wood
out if not
well we'll see so Matt you ready let's
do it
[Music]
that's not your blade it's okay okay
yes
I did it when I what I saw as I was
prying this out was that blade flexed
quite a bit at the tip and then that
wood gave way it's nice it's it's got
just enough movement
that it didn't fracture the neck's still
true here well done thank you Lyle
you're up next you ready yes sir I'm
ready
foreign
expecting the tip to break off my heart
just fell out of its place
as I started to go to the side there
wasn't any Flex in that blade much at
all it just popped right off
everything's been fun but this looks dim
for me
the judges have made a final decision
the forged and fire Champion is
Matt congratulations congratulations man
thank you
while your blade did not make the cut
please surrender your weapon
oh for the opportunity it's been a great
experience thank you once a tip broke
off I expected this I gave it my best
shot congratulations thank you I can go
home my head held high I enjoyed it I
made something I was proud of it was
just an oversight on my part
Matt congratulations you were the forest
and fire champion and we'll be receiving
that check for 10 grand good job thank
you
[Applause]
I don't know if you realize but I flexed
that blade to at least 45 degrees before
it popped that piece of wood out it
scared me when you did that I thought it
scared of me
this is amazing this is really cool I
can't believe I did it obviously what
you're going for but to have it happened
is
oh that's cool
the zande spear
boy one of the deadliest weapons used by
the zande tribes of central Africa the
zande spear was used for fighting as
well as for hunting known throughout
history as conquering Warriors the
Sunday exhibited unmatched skills on the
battlefield the fix to a wooden shaft
the spear was suitable for throwing and
attacking from long distances but his
thrusting ability made it just as
effective as a close combat weapon the
sharp upper and lower tines multiple
spikes inflicted deadly wounds both upon
entry and exit from the victim's body
the zande's lethal use of the spear can
be seen highlighted in the game
deadliest Boyer
bladesmiths I will take your Sunday
Spear and deliver killing blows on this
ballistic study two you're up first you
ready let's make those intestines out
testings all right let's do that I like
that
[Music]
right now I'm about to hear Doug say it
will heal and that's the only thing I'm
here for
to help me out today please welcome back
RJ markaida he will have the pleasure of
wielding your zombie spear
oh
[Music]
right drew it feels very good in the
hand it lacerates deep when we thrust
this into the chest cavity Into the
Heart on its way out not only does it
take some skin with it but it also took
out some ribs your times right here from
the side entry the spear went all the
way through and on its way out it took
everything that was in its path but
there is one issue as you can see your
tip right here broke off
but other than that this is a weapon
that is deadly and it will kill thank
you
all right Jason your turn you ready I
know it all cut
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right Jason the balance of your
weapon feels good when it penetrated
into the chest cavity it hit a rib and
broke it in half got into the heart and
there was no Edge damage on your tip all
these hooks right here did what it's
supposed to do into the abdomen ripped
everything out even the Barb and the
beautiful thing about this is
it will kill
that's what I wanted to hear
say hello to my little friend here
today we're going to test the overall
strength and construction of your Zonday
Spears by well we're going to fire him
out of this Cannon and to this wood
block wall now I'm not concerned about
what your Spears do to the wall I want
to see how well your Spears survive the
wall Drew you're up first you ready no
well we're gonna do it anyway let's do
it
that worked really well Drew
despite the fact that you did lose a
little bit of your tip in the kill test
didn't have any effect going into that
block wall matter of fact you sunk all
the way down here very impressive your
shaft is fine nothing loosened up
nothing cracked your spear head is still
solid overall
survives very good thank you
so Jason what are you thinking thinking
let's make splinters
that's a problem
oh God no
I'm seeing it hang up a bit on the
barrel and my heart just absolutely
sinks
okay
Jason we've got a big problem here the
parameters that we set for these weapons
are for testing purposes because your
blade didn't meet the inch and a half
parameter with a circular cross section
we cannot fit the shaft of your weapon
down the barrel of our testing apparatus
here and because we can't test it evenly
and fairly with Drew's blade I have to
ask you to please leave the forge
this was absolutely worst case scenario
I'm proud that I got this far but I'm
incredibly disappointed
well Drew in a competition where
attention to detail is just as critical
as craftsmanship you are the fortune
fire champion and will be collecting a
check for ten thousand dollars good job
oh
how do you feel right now
I'm 18 year old and I'm the fortune fire
Champion what what just happened well I
think the best blade just won my friend
come over here and Shake our hands oh
didn't want to win this way but I won
and that's kind of all that matters I
started bladesmithing seriously because
of this show I learned all that I had to
learn to make it here and I just won
this this is the dream oh my God man
the boar spear
developed as early as 700 A.D in Europe
the boar spear was forged for both
combat and hunting known at the time as
a bar spare the weapon was about five to
six feet long and featured a pair of
lugs below the leaf-shaped blade when
hunting the lugs would stop a speared
boar from running up the length of the
weapon and attacking the user
in combat the lugs can be used to hook
and pull away enemy Shields
the spear can be decorated with some
featuring finally engraved scenes of
Hunts on the first season of Game of
Thrones king Robert Baratheon carried a
boar spear on his final boar hunt Lane
Smith's this is the sharpness test to
see how sharp your boar Spears are we
will test the tip in the Edge by
stabbing and slashing through these
sandbags all right Clayton you're up
first you ready I'm ready
well Clayton the balance of your tip
lends itself to stabbing your Edge
lacerated cleanly on a moving sandbag
what surprised me was the positioning of
your lug traditionally they have it
crosswise this way but you have it this
way because of that it was hard to index
when you're cutting through
but then again it will cut thank you
Alan you're next ready oh yeah
well Alan your spear feels good to hold
on to it was easy to index and know
where the edge was so that was a nice
slash that I could penetrate through and
in the thrust it felt good in the hand
I can see a little bow in your handle
but when we're talking about the
sharpness test
this sir will cut all right
next up is a kill test
to see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon can do I will deliver lethal
blows to this wild boar carcass taping
you up first are you ready absolutely
foreign
well Clayton
your borsby right here did very well on
the thrust penetrating all the way
through on the low line and on The High
Line
on the edge you lacerated cleanly and
testing the other side it cut all the
way through the spine
this sir will kill good job thank you
Alan you're next you ready oh yeah let's
do this
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about your blade on the
thrust it penetrated all the way through
on the laceration on one side of your
Edge boy wow it almost sliced all the
way through
on your other Edge it lacerated through
the spine
this piercer will kill all right
next up is a strength test Dave the
gentleman it's been said that the sword
is the prince of all weapons but the
spear is the king to test the strength
of your boar Spears I'm going to load
them into our air cannon here and fire
them into this wooden Target it's a fun
test
down
just can't wait we'll see how deep it
penetrates how well it holds up and if
it holds up while I remove the spear
from the target awesome Clayton you're
up first you ready I am all right let's
do this
oh man I'm just hoping that my handle
stays together I'm hoping that after it
impacts the wood it doesn't break the
blade off or something like that
and
three
two
one
sure
well Clayton your spear really dug in
deep it went in about four inches came
out fine everything still
tight and dialed in this is interesting
being offset being in support spirit I
wanted to make sure that whatever
laceration the blade produced on the
animal wasn't wide enough to allow the
wings to come through and the best way
to do that was just make them
perpendicular
all right nicely done thank you Alan
you're up
in three
two
one
[Music]
all right Alan that buried itself quite
nicely went into about there again about
four inches deep like the leaf shape on
this I like the fact that you hand
hammered the socket I was kind of
worried when I put this in our machine
that's like warp in your shaft there
would bind up
but not a problem
good job thank you
blade Smiths the judges have completed
their deliberation and they've made a
final decision both of you have turned
in fantastic boar Spears however in this
Arena of competition there can only be
one forged and fire champion
[Music]
congratulations you are the forged and
fire champion
regulations you did awesome
Clayton your boar Spirit did not make
the cut Clayton this was not an easy
decision to make because of your
perpendicular lugs it was hard to
visually index your blade meaning it's
hard to tell where the Cutting Edge is
that makes it a less effective weapon
and for that we have to let you go I
understand
Clayton
please surrender your weapon
right now obviously I'm a little bit
disappointed but this is the first spear
I made and for me it's really important
that it was such a tight race I don't
want it to be anything that I handed him
or anything that he would have handed me
Alan is a deserving champion
Alan congratulations you are the fortune
fire champion and with that comes a
check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations thank you
I appreciate about that is the fact that
you took the time to actually Hammer
that cone out making that socket is a
really nice touch on any kind of
traditional spear well done I I am the
forged and fire Champion I cannot
believe it I had no idea if it was going
to be me or him and
it was me I'm betting being a fortune
fire Champion is going to help this
stay-at-home dad slash knife maker
convinced a few people that they should
try out my blades that's great
foreign
spirit
the Messiah lion spear gets its name
from an East African tribe of fearsome
Warrior Nomads that date their Origins
back to the 15th century traditionally
used to hunt lions the weapon features a
double-edged blade at one end and a
fearsome Spike at the other this allows
a messiah Warrior to engage his opponent
in close quarters or at a distance
while today lion hunts have been
replaced the deadly spear lives on in
popular culture and can even be spotted
in the film Laura Croft Tomb Raider the
Cradle of life to see how lethal your
weapon is I will take your Spear and
deliver lethal blows on this big carcass
Matt you're up first are you ready as
I'll ever be let's do this
what I'm most worried about is lateral
force on this spear because it's a very
thin Sleek spear
well
that sucks
Matt I'm not gonna sugarcoat it this is
bad your weapon has suffered a
catastrophic failure and cannot continue
with testing however John we can't just
declare you the forged and fire Champion
your blade has to hold up for at least a
stab and a slash on this carcass Doug
foreign
I don't know what to say I don't know
what to think I've never been more you
know nervous in my life
I'm hoping and praying that it doesn't
break in the same spot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
weapons to the Limit John your blade
survived the two cuts on our carcass
Matt that means unfortunately your blade
did not make the cut and I have to ask
you to please leave the forge
I'm disappointed given what I know now I
would have gone back and really tried
chopping some things very hard with the
spirit hopefully broken the handle
myself I'm really happy for John maybe
I'm not happy to lose to John but I'm
glad John Won
John congratulations you built a weapon
that held up in our test that makes you
our new forged and fire champion who
also receives a check for 10 grand
how you feel right now I feel like a
million bucks but I guess 10 grand will
do all right well come on over here and
Shake our hands good job but thank you
very good I'm gonna have to uh talk to
my wife about what I'm allowed to do
with this prize money I know one thing
my baby girl is gonna get in a little
new wardrobe
[Music]
the boar sword
specifically designed for the hunt the
boar sword originated from 16th century
Germany featuring a long reinforced
Blade with a spear Lake head this weapon
was built to both thrust and withstand
the power of a charging bore the weapon
also contained a cross piece built into
the blade that functioned as a guard to
stop the animal from sliding down the
weapon and injuring the user given its
highly specific nature bore swords were
never used extensively by the public or
by militaries but were the favorite
hunting weapon of the founder of the
lanschneck mercenaries and patriarch of
the Habsburg Dynasty 16th Century Holy
Roman Emperor Maximilian
all right bladesmiths to test The
lethality of your boar swords I will
deliver thrusts and cuts on this for
carcass
John you're first you ready for this
absolutely
lucky
I can't wait to see what my sword does
to that bull I want to see whether or
not it will kill
[Music]
all right John first up I like the
balance I like that I can put two hands
in it it's all void enough to where I
can hold on and I can tell where the
edge is and when we're pushing and
thrusting as it's meant to be the tip is
sharp enough to thrust all the way
through your edges as you can see are
sharp enough to cut pieces out of these
four carcass overall sir it'll kill
thanks sir congrats thanks man
all right Isaac your turn are you ready
for this let's make some bacon
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys first stop it's much
lighter so it's easier to control when
you're moving with a blade and as you
can see when I was thrusting in there
the point you have here the edges are
very sharp it thrusts all the way in and
even when it gets bone it's got a very
good Flex to it to not pick up a pen
overall sir you're a boar sword
will make bacon and kill
thank you
gentlemen it's time for the strength
test the sheet metal stab
now to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades I'll be
stabbing into the sheet metal but this
test is not about what your blades do to
that Target it's about what that Target
does to your blades Jonathan you're here
first you ready absolutely
[Music]
foreign
all right Jonathan your blade is still
sharp pretty much all the way to the tip
now the tip did get flattened a little
bit but that was a very very acute tip
that you had on there all in all it's a
comfortable weapon it's certainly held
up beautifully nice and done thank you
all right Isaac are you ready for this
as ready as I'm gonna be
[Music]
so
there's definitely a significant Bend
all right there's a good Flex in your
blade which we saw in an earlier test
but when you quench this blade I'm
assuming right in here somewhere was
where that quench stopped so this is not
really solid right here
you did lose your tip up here but your
edges held up it's still sharp but you
can just see there's an obvious issue
with that bend there
all right blade space this is the
sharpness test
find out if there's any sharpness left
on your tip and edges I will take your
weapon and stab and slash at this deer
height now unlike the strength test this
is all about what your blade will do to
this deer height John you're first you
ready for this let's do it
foreign
[Music]
looking at the tip here I can see where
it flattened out took a little bit of
effort to be able to puncture through
but it did your edges are so sharp the
cuts are clean overall sir
you have a cut thanks sir all right is
that your turn sir you ready I am
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
the damage to your tip on the strength
that's really took it out there is no
tip to this anymore I can put my finger
on that but the edge of your blade on
both sides as you can see cut all the
way through now the interesting thing to
note is that all that bending actually
straightened your blade
overall sir
beautiful cut thank you
blade Smith's the judges have
deliberated right here on the forge
floor they've made their final decision
Isaac your blade didn't make the cut
your blade took a bend in the strength
test and for that reason I have to ask
you to please leave a forge
well Jonathan it would appear that
Warrior ethos runs deep in you because
not only are you an active duty Marine
you are also the forged and fire
Champion that's a title that comes with
a check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations
being for the fire Champion it feels
great
it's a boost of confidence it's not the
big things that really matter it's the
little things the attention and detail
that that make a big difference